our next guest she's a very familiar
face on television
critically acclaimed actress this is
juliana margulies is known for playing
very strong female leads in hit dramas
she became a household name back in the
1990s with a breakout role in the
medical drama i love this show er
starring opposite george clooney dad
i don't want to wake up a lot tomorrow
[Music]
they were so good together her character
nurse carol how the way does that take
me backwards originally
listen to this she was not even supposed
to survive past the pilot
but she ended up stealing the audience's
hearts and she won her first emmy award
margulies went on to win two more emmys
for her role as alicia florek on the hit
cbs show
the good wife and her new memoir
sunshine girl and unexpected
life she shares intimate details from
her childhood and life as an actress
juliana morgeles joins us now juliana i
want to talk about er of course but i
first want to start with your book
because you say listen you're the o
you're the youngest rather of three
girls
and you said that when you're the
youngest you admit you got away with a
lot of stuff including
this is i found it's hard to believe
about you obnoxious and loud in school
you sort of became the clock class class
clown to fit in
i just don't see you that way juliana
margulies what was going on in your
brain at that time
no well that was um i think that was so
i write about that time in my life
because
it was when i had left england and come
back to america and i was trying to fit
in with the kids
and i noticed that a lot of the girls
were tomboys and i thought that maybe if
i
acted like more like a boy and i could
get attention that way and fit in that
way so for a while i was actually
nicknamed julie animal yeah
as a as a fourth and uh third and fourth
grader
um by fifth grade i i started getting
crushes on boys and realized
that it was much better perhaps not to
beat them up but to um
to try and get them to like me so i
stopped i stopped being julie animal
after that
yeah but i was i was loud and obnoxious
yeah i know that's hard to believe boys
can be a good thing you're right too
your
life was pretty chaotic that both your
mom and your dad were complicated
tell us a little bit about your your
background and yet despite all that your
mom still called you sunshine girl which
is where the title of the book comes
from
yeah so my mother named me sunshine girl
um when i was pretty much
a little tiny baby i was never that tiny
because i weighed ten pounds four ounces
when i came out wow
wow so i don't think you could ever
actually ever call me a tiny tiny baby
um but she named me sunshine girl
because i didn't cry and i was always
smiling and
and that nickname um although i wore it
as a badge of honor for most of my
childhood because i thought oh i make
people feel good
also could be crippling as i got older
and didn't know how to
say no to things or was always worried
about making someone upset if i said no
that doesn't work for me this works for
me
so that that nickname um
i realized as i got older actually was
not um
was not such a badge of honor in my
adult life well listen you made a lot of
headlines when you said no to er you had
been on the show for
six seasons and uh they had offered you
you were leaving but they offered you 27
million
dollars to stay for another two years i
think you were 31 32 at the time
and you said no to that i read that and
i thought gosh if i was in that position
what i've said no my answer was
no i would not have said no i would have
stayed another two years but you turned
it down why
that was unheard of at the time
yeah and i only wrote about it
because it seems to have defined me in
this business in a way that
i never imagined so i wrote about it to
put it to rest to be honest with you
i wanted people to hear my side of the
story everyone had their own
ideas of who i was and why i would do
something so crazy and i
i admit it's crazy i'm not um
i'm not stupid i understand why people
were so
taken aback by that um so i write about
it in the book and one of
one of the main reasons
i i said no was first of all my six-year
contract was over
george clooney and i really were um
meant to be together on that show and
when he left in the fifth season and i
had one year to go
which i was happy to do um i felt like
my
time was up and it was time to pass on
to the next person who would play
that kind of a character maybe not nurse
hathaway specifically but
carry on in that kind of a role as least
as a head nurse
and um i had already secured a play
john robin bates had written this play
called the ten unknowns which he had
given me the summer before
saying he wrote the part with me in mind
would i do it
i had already signed on to do the miss
of avalon which was a
four-month job in the czech r in in
prague
in the czech republic and i was going to
go and ride horses which i was a
horseback rider as a child so i sort of
had a year already
planned and then she was booked in
business um
you were booked i was booked and busy
but also also i was ready to come home
i'm i'm a new yorker i'm from the east
coast and i'd been in la for
six years and my parents were here my
family was here and
and i had i wasn't married i i had
already paid my mortgage
to me i was living the life i thought
this is what i've always dreamed of of
being able to go and do the work
i was going off to do a play for 235
dollars a week it's not like
well i love juliana timmy i love that
you said in the book everybody said well
you wouldn't have
27 million you wouldn't have to work
anymore and i thought well that's a
ridiculous idea i want to work
yeah that was a strange argument to me
and that was pretty much everyone's
argument was you'll never have to work
again and i
i thought but i i love what i do and er
has afforded me uh
hopefully at least at that time i felt a
lifetime of acting
and so these all these opportunities
were dangling in front of me
and the only thing that would have
stopped me from taking them was
money and to me i mean my father really
helped me
um with that decision when he said
what if you got hit by a bus while you
were waiting for those two years to go
by
so you could get rich what would your
last thoughts be
when you were lying there dying yeah how
did you live your last
moments did you live them truthfully or
were you waiting for money because you
don't leave this planet with anything in
your pocket but your soul right
thank you mr margulies we we were
teasing about george calling you
briefly because we got to go what did
george call you to say because you said
that phone call changed
your life yeah so i had i had come back
from doing the pilot i died in the pilot
my character died in the pilot i came
back from doing the pilot and i was
about to take another job and george
left a message saying
i hear your character tested really well
um please don't take another job i think
they're going to offer you
a series regular um yeah i took a gamble
and thank god for george
thank you george clooney also juliana
thank you so much do you know how good
you have to be though you're going to
get killed off in the pilot and they say
you know we should keep her
bring her back to life let's bring her
back to life the name of the book is
called sunshine girl
it goes on sale tomorrow wherever you
like to buy your books